today's topic dante wright just miles
from where george floyd died
a police officer shot and killed a young
unarmed black man
reigniting outrage and inflaming
tensions
minneapolis of course was already on
edge as the nation
watches the murder trial of derek
chauvin the police chief in brooklyn
center that's the suburb
outside the city says cops pulled over
20-year-old dante
wright for expired tags and tried to
arrest him for an outstanding warrant
there was a struggle the police chief
says one of the officers pulled out her
gun
by mistake thinking it was her taser
and fired today the police chief
released body cam video of the shooting
is she a new officer no she's a veteran
25 years
maybe i'm wrong look it up 26 year
veteran
that's right i was off by a year
your gun your gun when your cop is on
your dominant dominant hand
it's your dominant hand so if you're
right
handed your gun's gonna be on your right
your taser is gonna be on your left
when you shoot your taser and you yell
taser taser taser
because that's what they she did i'm not
watching the video if you got to watch
it you go watch it
you yell taser taser taser and you have
your gun in your hand
distraction i guess i don't know it gets
really redundant to do these videos
where we break things
down or try to or whatever it's just it
always comes back to the same thing
whether it's by seas or poor training
like i just
i have very little respect for
that kind of for an occupation with so
many privileges and
and responsibility yeah so so much power
and
privilege yet so little responsibility
that's what it comes down to maybe it's
just how it's raised maybe it's because
the fact that i've seen how things work
in the army but like
like these kinds of mistakes that the
cops get away with would never fly in
the army so that's why i'm just like i
can't respect it
you know i mean like when you have more
responsibilities with how you handle
foreign citizens in a foreign country as
a soldier
it strikes me as completely odd that we
have more responsibilities than like
those kind of areas those combat zones
right but then you have police officers
who handle your own local citizens
not being held accountable for the stuff
that they do do you know why you had a
warrant
because they didn't send
the notice for a hearing on the court to
the right address
oh she had a warrant because it well you
know that's an administrative and a
systemic problem
that's an administrative let's say no
yeah i'm just saying if you put all that
[ __ ] together
and it's a series of unfortunate events
and i get that and you know what
to the people was like i'm not even i
don't it's not even the fact that he's
black
he would have been right white i would
have a problem with this [ __ ]
that's not right there's a lot of people
that yeah but you know we don't hear you
talk when there's white people it
happens to white people either
it doesn't make it better yeah and why
would you come to this discussion with
that rhetoric
considering like if you really care
about
these white victims and whatnot then
police reform benefits them as well
so what's the point of you be like what
about if you want to
make sure that police are held
accountable and that their training is
improved
you wouldn't say that yeah that's such
stupid rhetoric
yeah i mean that's wrong so so it's just
like to me i find this whole
discussion redundant i watch these
videos i'm like and now the police chief
has also resigned after this incident
it's like
why are you resigning why because
there's a mistake and you don't want to
handle the pressure
of being responsible for the poor
training of your own people that you
employ it's crazy to me bro it's crazy
to me it was [ __ ] imagining
they hit the floor yeah you don't want a
leadership and you just book it like
get the [ __ ] out of here man hey he did
jeep released body cam video of the
shooting
and a warning now the video is hard to
do that's the body camera you don't want
to see it play it but we pause it
pause that and a warning now the video
is hard to watch
we're going to play it but we pause it
pause that video at the moment of the
fatal [ __ ]
gun shot
all right i don't think i need to see
anymore no it's not going to enlighten
your perspective or whatever i mean i
don't know i don't know
what what else what else to say about
that i mean i feel like we said
everything that has to be said
so i'm i'm i'm tired i'm done i'm not
yeah yeah i mean
at some point you just um you see it so
often you just become
used to it i mean you become kind of
used to it whether you're the one on the
receiving end
of the [ __ ] you know and we only see
the most violent deadly stuff
oftentimes it's the little things day by
day that make you apathetic
and make you super jaded when it comes
to law enforcement
it's the unnecessary searches for no
reason it's the oh
you you match a suspect and then you
find out that like there's nothing to it
to more than that it's like
it's just like sometimes it's just the
constant annoyances
oh you were driving five uh five
kilometers five miles under the speed
limit
so why are you bothering i'm on my way
to work like why are y'all harassing
this is unnecessary when you get stopped
multiple times a month man man
when i lived in los angeles for a couple
years bro i would get stopped on my
bicycle multiple times
i'm like why i'll stop and say oh we
just patrolling we want to ask you a
couple questions
i'm like is there something happening
it's like no but you're going to say
that i was like
but why is this why are you bothering me
they're bored
all right and they have all these powers
just like man i i
yeah i don't know sometimes just the
you know the people that they're like
they're there protect and serve but the
serve part really doesn't feel like it's
there sometimes
it feels like it's it's like protecting
and oppressed at times
and and and that's that's something you
don't see who are you protecting
you know and that's the stuff that you
don't see on cam sometimes it's like
it's like the day-to-day stuff that just
really eats at you and gets in the way
like man
you know and when you're wronged all
right and when you're wronged or you're
unjustly
you know bothered or whatever it's just
like it especially when you don't get an
apology afterwards after they realized
that they were wrong that
[ __ ] sits with you they're that kind
of indignation of like
it's like our tax dollars go to pay your
salary
and even and you have this like arrogant
smug feel about you like
you're not here for the public did you
forget you're a public servant
i could not imagine being an army and
then having that kind of attitude
towards civilians
to civilians that you know you're meant
to protect i couldn't imagine
well i couldn't imagine and i couldn't
imagine working as a government official
you know when i worked when i worked in
the government and i was like
i couldn't imagine talking to the
citizens like that when i'm supposed to
serve them i just don't get it i just
don't get it sometimes so
when i see this kind of stuff it's just
like bruh well that's the reason why you
got people like you know
else angels and stuff like that you go
to war you become a veteran
you come back to the civilian life and
they have no respect for you and they do
whatever the hell they want to do
they they they they just talk like
and walk like they went to war they
disrespect you and then you got a group
like that marginalized group like that
i i understand i understand where it's
from like i get it i mean
at this at this point yeah i don't even
know what to do
neither do i but hey maybe you guys have
a different opinion like i said
just the most poorly trained group i
can't i can't i can't
so those are my thoughts on the matter
[Music]
me
you